yeah hello and welcome to this video
very happy to make this video it's very
different to the to the normal ones
because some interesting and exciting
news to share so what is it about as you
see already in the background it's about
keep it simple 1.e4 repertoire something
that you very likely have heard of quite
a bit on my channel at sort of surprise
it's one of them most important projects
that I have done probably the most
important released on chasuble on march
12 2018 a couple of months ago and yeah
it was very well received cause as you
can see here it's a little bit it's a
little bit small a share but we have
more than 1,000 students now who
purchased the repertoire a lot of them
with the videos of all 18 hours and the
Omo reception has been really great yeah
we've got an average 4.9 out of 5 stars
based on 122 user ratings that sounds
great
yeah and it was some not a long time ago
after the release of the course then in
fact new in chess the well known
probably the biggest publishing company
for chests contacted me and they asked
me well this is a cool product we want
to make a book out of it
and I agreed to translate the whole
thing into a traditional print book and
now we've call it yeah this is keep it
simple money form as a traditional print
book yeah as much as I love online
online courses it is cool to have it
just like sitting in your hand yeah it's
it's pretty nice and it's a great
companion also simply for them for the
online version it's nice to just put it
in your back and have it ready when you
I don't know write on the train or
something it can be more convenient than
do it on a on an electronic device in
some cases so what's you we got a new
book out and this is a real milestone
also for the chest-wall side that
chasuble product has been converted
basically into a traditional print book
so many things going on around around
this thing let me start with what we're
doing on chasuble
to celebrate that that book is out a
couple of things are going on first of
all you can win some copies of the book
they will be signed by me and this is
actually quite easy to do I'm going to
switch the page em and I'll link all of
that of course in the description of the
video yeah so there is a there is a
price giveaway more than one thousand
dollars in prices and you know what what
can you win it's it's nice we've got ten
of those books for you with my signature
that is not yet side right no not yet I
will do it so 10 10 books we will give
two winners then six winners I get a
two-year chess of a pro membership which
is also worth about $100 and then there
will be one prize winner who gets a
video lesson like a Skype call on
whatever you choose with me to discuss
whatever you like about chess if you
want to discuss the repertoire it's cool
but you can also yeah I don't know yeah
talk about theoretical head games we'll
see what happens so yeah you get to hook
up with me for a very old lesson and how
do you win that it's actually not
difficult it looks a little bit busy
down there but what does that mean you
can just enter this competition by I
think you need to give you email right
yeah you give me to give you email to
give get some weight or to allow some
way to contact you if you win but you
can actually increase your chances if
you do a couple of things here for
example you get a bonus if you are
subscribed to my youtube channel or you
get a bonus if you follow chasuble on
twitter or if you go onto Facebook and
view
do I have a suspicion what Fulton la
acción this is the photo of the books
you see that it's a little bit down
there yeah so it's pretty easy to
increase your chances just do a couple
of those things it probably depends a
little bit how many social media
accounts you have and how much you yeah
want to follow and so on it's it's easy
to increase your chances and there's
some nice surprises there are still 18
days left to do that so it's not a huge
urge to do it but it's cool already 1200
entries it's amazing we we send a mail
out I think a little bit earlier today
so if you want to win a copy of the book
or just super Pro memberships or yeah I
get to meet me online that's the way to
do it so the other thing is on chesil
itself if we go back them we have done
something with with the online version
of it what we what we did is we actually
added a little bit of content because
the paper book the print book is almost
identical to the chasuble thing it's
almost identical I had I changed one or
two things in terms of moves let's say
and edit one or two things that are also
going to be added to the chasuble
product in no time but that is like not
even one percent of the content the main
difference is that the book contains 30
additional instructive games to show how
you play after the first opening moves
so it is an additional way to understand
better what's going on right after the
initial moves these are 30 fully
annotated games and ten of them we have
now integrated into the chasuble course
that is you can see here we have
currently this has 58,000 words this
course this is a lot actually I mean
it's it's tough to tell you
you don't don't use this kind of count
58,000 words is a lot yeah it's it's
really yeah if you like this book will
probably have 70,000 or 75 or something
so because it has 30 games and now ten
of the ten of those thirty are part of
the chester book course so with added
value for all the one thousand people
who who bought it already they have
additional things to learn and study and
what's going on is form what is that ten
days I think for ten days we would have
a sale of the product where the video
course in particular is a lot cheaper
than usual so if you have already gotten
the the move trainer you can add the
video for half the price or you can buy
the whole thing also for a reduced price
for ten days so this is also a nice
opportunity if you'd like to have the
video to support you with the book with
the online with the course everything
together I think it's a really really a
great package to learn to learn the
repertoire one thing the copies the one
about the book how do you can how can
you get the book and it is as you see I
have got a copy and I've got more behind
me in my shelves but it is really really
new so I'm probably really the first
person who has gotten any of the books
last Friday and they're currently
arriving in shops yeah I think you will
probably be able to order it by Amazon
and at other typical platforms but there
are some other opportunities that you
have that I want to show to you yeah you
can order it directly from you and share
sold so if you go into new and chance
and you want to view sample pages for
example that's a way to get more
information but one thing that I
definitely want to point you to is the
opportunity to get signed copies of the
book and now and to switch to a
different online store and as you see
here keep it simple 1.e4 Ziggy niet
scienter it's a German it's a german
shop
yeah whatever dunya
I wanted to yeah make sure that you get
signed copies also yeah quickly and
well-organized I have sent out signed
copies of my first book myself three
years ago and it was kind of it was a
huge effort really because I got so many
orders and sometimes I really got
confused there because I did this person
pay whatever it was really complicated
so I'm actually teaming up for selling
some signed copies with a friend of mine
who has a chess made on a business and
if you use his or his shop simply you
can get the signed copies from there
this is yeah the website is
www.jfn.co.jp/toho but it's it's a
German shop and the German and person
who was running it and he will send out
signed copies for the normal retail
price so there is no additional cost and
you can order in a shop basically from
all over Europe so if you are from
Europe from Germany from the UK from
France whatever then you can easily
order copies there just for the normal
retail price you have no additional
costs so it is the 30 euros and
depending on where you are he will
charge you delivery costs their form for
mailing the book if you are outside of
Europe that won't work
he doesn't send to a New Zealand or
something for this kind of thing you can
also write to me directly I'm switching
the page yet again it is my keep it
simple style home page and here if
you're going to contact me you can send
me a with your name mayor and a message
you can message me and tell me okay I'd
like to order book and then we will sort
out the details if you order a book from
me directly please be aware that that
won't work like you you send it to me
and you get the book and in two days or
something that that won't work I'm
extremely busy also with other things
but
is something that will take a couple of
days let's say I'm not going to let you
wait for two month or something suggest
that you understand correctly but it
won't work as swiftly as if you are in
Europe and use use a shop system and
this is why I splitted this up if I
would have done both it's just not
possible
so if you've one signed copies you can
join the competition here I've got sent
ten signed copies to win if you're in
Germany or in Europe you can use that
online store and if you are outside of
that you can contact me directly if
you've got my mail address I'm not
unhappy about them out of mail as well
but the contact page is simplest to just
avoiding giving up my mail address yeah
I'm very happy about all this things are
going very well here with with the
release I got many people are messaging
me that they're interested about it and
yeah also make sure to take use of here
this this competition and the reduced
prices yon chasuble
for ten days it will be I would use
price to get the online product and yeah
the book is really a great companion to
that I really and I only have it since
Friday but I've used it ready he said
was it was it was funded during a
training session over the board it's
just sometimes handy and to just check
what was in the book again it's it's
quite quite nice to have so I'm happy
that you tuned in to the video and I
hope yeah you gotten some good
information out of it if you're
interested in the product lots of
interesting opportunities at the moment
thanks a lot for watching